hello we're a technician at Craig alley
here it's John Humphrey over here so d23
Expo released the thing that a lot of
people are requesting that we do a
reaction to a Star Wars the last Jedi
behind the scenes in case you missed our
video we gave a thorough explanation as
to why we're doing this it's really not
a big deal but I know some might find it
it'd be the reactions and the reviews
are going to be on separate videos
bottom line you know like a little more
than 50% of the people stop watching our
videos after the reaction but for the
people that like to watch the reviews of
the videos that we react to that'll be
on a separate video now right to that
and there's more explanation as to why
they're divided up but you know I quote
watch him in order yeah also we'll be
doing a shout out for Gareth do it
patron of the day because he asked
forever ago and says look you don't have
to give me a shout all the time
but when there's a last Jedi video I am
on a shout out and I said you okay I got
the hiccups till you shot it everybody
Wow thank God these other people say
what it int gosh the first sub didn't
even have a number
was that that's the camera a bunch of
blood I should pay you back why in the
house written a story that unexpected
but right nice however did some of the
stuff that happens people not only gosh
Oh even though I think I know it all
they Services has been story wise I
never could have imagined I even though
everybody knows it's the second in a
trilogy it feels like as I'm saying
Wow motive in Star Wars said I want that
sweater
Star Wars is so cool because there's all
these creatures
I always make visual effect
like all the characters are also so
complex come on Ernie
why at least what ways which is out to
do that we directly this together
[Music]
a frequent experience between was lost
forever tourism opportunities retail
places whole thing that the countess but
remain long
within bangle exchange
give city the way to a movie
technically yeah question
[Music]
children I think you'll be a little
shocking
[Music]
the most ancient of all evil building a
most welcome everyone
we really suits the sense to me
[Music]
devout family and that's what's so
powerful about it ah
Princess Leia quoting Vin Diesel the
latter in that year the defenders rumors
ah yay yay oh dear you know what's weird
I was pretty excited for the force
awakens I'm strangely looking forward to
this one even more than the force
awakens yeah I mean at least just
watching this I just feel the magic yeah
that's like working on a Star Wars movie
looks like the most magical place
doesn't it like you're a community and
there's all these magical things walking
around he's amazing I just want to be
here and I'm not even a big like I like
Star Wars but a huge Star Wars guy and
yet this got me like really like I can't
wait just yet everyone a lot of people
kept saying the same kind of thing about
Rian Johnson too like oh it's you know I
love the line day's release its
unexpected but yeah see what I want to
your business is you know what I feel
like you know knowing Rian Johnson's you
know filmography right now I feel like
he can definitely deliver something like
that live that might be the biggest draw
of this movie for me is I think Rian
Johnson is a terrific homemaker so I
yeah he can do this so our force awakens
just had to do it right after coming off
the prequel that were well-received
stickily and then they had to do a lot
of setting up and that's why I felt like
the be cheap on earth a new hope a lot
and now I feel like here's where they
can take it all in a brand new direction
now you know that we've been
reintroducing them satisfactory now we
can take it in a brand new direction and
that's what got me really excited all
the way this video was shot and edited I
guess I kept going back and forth - yes
have we put explosion fight casts
everybody exclamations black bean and it
gives you a lot of different things to
look at without really revealing too
much about yeah the way to not worship
promote themselves
yeah yeah hell yeah that line that they
end on with Carrie Fisher you know
saying how it's about family well part
of me goes on open diesel passengers
that is hard Reagan in here you feel it
you feel it and and for anyone who's
like seen documentaries
or interviews you're like that's that's
pretty much who Carrie Fisher is all
right well we'll do a discussion on a
separate video
hey thanks to all you who let me know
this video is out but before we end this
video Garen hood G train Gareth hood
more like Garrett good cuz he's a good
guy because he's a great guy he's got a
son dad of the year coffee mug he's got
cool British accent yeah cool beard he's
British and every time he's one of our
Google hamster we have on patreon he
always starts off with going sweep your
chimney old wheel will yeah yeah he's
always got tea and he just perpetually
dips a crumb you know I'm school toy and
he never eats the crumpet he just keeps
the entity
I love the coin and I'm one of our
hangouts he conquered an entire nation
more favorite movies the only thing
Edgar won't related tears I love you who
the Google hangout and Gareth hood he's
oozing that he's in the Middle East and
he stayed up till 4:00 in the morning or
o'clock just to be on a Google hangout
that lasted till 5:00 in the morning his
time yeah dude you need to do something
better with your life like increase your
pledge on page your your your message
thank you render your G double OT anyway
subscribe to the real rejects coop that
notifications out that John Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram social media
manager Blum house and take care made
the trek be with